So this is our superscalar versus VLIW quiz
solution. We have an [INAUDIBLE] superscalar with a 32
bit instruction. And we have a VLIW processor,
where it really packages up to four such instructions
into a 128 bit instruction. If we manage
to package four instructions into one of these. Then
the size is the same, four of these are equal to the size of one of these.
So the program size, at best, will be the
same, 4000 bytes. However, it can happen for example that
all of these instructions depend on each other. In
which case we can specify only one of them in
each one of these. We have to fill the
rest of the 128 bit instruction with three no ops,
simply because there are no two instructions from this
program that can actually fit in the same instruction here,
because they depend on each other. And all we can put in a VLIW instruction are
operations. That are independent of each other. So, what could happen is that we
have a program that is really four times larger, which is 16000 bytes.